merci bien Antoine de nous accompagner
durant cette première demi-heure
sénateur du Tarn-et-Garonne demande du
groupe Union centriste on va parler
évidemment de la loi pleine emploi que
le Sénat voté cette nuit mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est ce 14 juillet qui
approchait les services de sécurité qui
a l'air sur un risque de reprise des
émeutes à l'occasion de la fête
nationale est-ce que vous vous sentez la
situation explosive est-ce qu'il faut
annuler certaines festivités du 14
juillet
non salut le 14 juillet est une fête qui
est attendue par tous les Français c'est
leur fête nationale c'est une fête où
ils aiment se retrouver à voir les feux
d'artifice aiment danser et aujourd'hui
annuler des festivités ça serait montré
que finalement la République est plus
faible que les délinquants on a retrouvé
le calme il y a quelques jours bon je
salue l'action des forces de l'ordre
encore une fois qui ont été très
efficaces qui n'ont pas arrêté d'être
sur le terrain pour faire face à des
émeutiers très extrêmement violents qui
ont tiré à balles réel il faut encore
une fois le rappeler non je ne suis pas
d'accord alors vous savez l'an dernier
on a annulé des feux d'artifice pour
sécheresse cette année abattant annuler
des feux d'artifice parce qu'on a peur
de d'émeutes non je pense qu'il faut
mettre en place des dispositifs de
sécurité adéquat en fonction des villes
mais il faut pas annuler il faut pas
privilégier les Français de ce grand
moment elle a notamment annoncé
l'interdiction de la vente elle
transporte de mortier c'est suffisant
une première décision très importante
parce que je crois quand même quand je
procure très facilement des mortiers
d'artifice dont on voit l'utilisation
pour faire joli c'est pour attaquer nos
forces de l'ordre donc il faut
réglementer encore de manière encore
plus drastique ces ventes de de mortiers
et derrière mettre en place encore une
fois le processus de sécurité mais
soyons vigilants mais laissons aussi les
Français un peu changer les esprits
qui ont été touchées il y a une loi
d'urgence qui serait examinée par le
Parlement la semaine prochaine elle sera
présentée demain en Conseil des
ministres c'est une loi très courte
est-ce que vous la mettrait
alors c'est déjà une initiative
sénatoriales je rappelle que Sophie
prima à BP l'initiative de déposer une
loi pour faire accélérer les processus
de reconstruction c'est une loi
d'habilitation qui va être assez rapide
je crois trois articles qui devraient
présenter en conseil des ministres
aujourd'hui et ensuite au Sénat arrivé
au Sénat des mardi on va autoriser le
président de la République à légiférée
par ordonnance on n'aime pas trop ça au
Sénat mais on va le faire parce qu'il
faut aller vite il faut permettre à nos
mairies de lancer les travaux de
reconstruction très rapidement sans
attendre forcément les autorisations
d'urbanisme permettre également de
déroger au seuil des 80% de subvention
de également de réglementer peut-être
d'assouplir la règle de marché public
avec publicité vous voyez tout ceci fait
que nous voulons nous aller vite au
Sénat ce qu'on veut c'est permettre la
reconstruction identique avec bien sûr
tant qu'à faire une performance
environnementale plus aguerri mieux et
mieux déterminer mais il faut qu'on
fasse vraiment fille de ce qui s'est
passé
reconstruire et après on supposera les
bonnes questions pour savoir comment
doit-on tirer les leçons de ce qui s'est
passé les sanctions
qui payent les assurances vont payer
mais qui paye voilà donc là c'est
l'urgence cité à reconstruction mais du
coup les assurances où est-ce qu'il
sont là pour payer un risque qui est
déterminé mais rendez-vous compte tous
ces pillages combien ça coûte aux
assurances et au final qui c'est qui
paye c'est les Français donc il faut
bien sûr il faut avoir cette réflexion
se poser les bonnes questions et surtout
le faire à tête reposer et sur les
autres sanctions les républicains dépose
une proposition de loi pour suspendre le
RSA les allocations familiales en tout
cas pour les parents de mineurs
délinquance ça va dans le bon sens pour
vous pourriez voter un tel texte je
pense qu'il faut avoir encore une fois
une discussion apaisée il ne faut jamais
prendre de décision dans l'émotion ça
serait une mauvaise un mauvais signal
qu'on donne à nos concitoyens je pense
qu'il faut oui
encore une fois c'est dans une majorité
sénatoriale on a des discussions on peut
avoir des oppositions et des points de
convergence il faut qu'on en discute
ensemble et après on verra comment on a
comment on amende les textes on a vu sur
les différents textes nous avons
présenté ensemble mais il faut le faire
de manière
empêcher une amende forfaitaire pour les
mineurs ça vous paraît plus une
meilleure solution que la suspension de
location familiale
il faut également aussi parler peut-être
de la baisse de la l'âge de la majorité
pénale ça aussi c'est un vrai sujet vous
savez on a des ça c'est une vraie
question qui revient au Sénat on est
certain qu'ils veulent de 13 à 16 ans
d'autres à partir de 16 ans la question
de la suppression de l'excuse de
minorité aussi c'est un truc tout à fait
bien
Elisabeth borne aujourd'hui syndicat et
patronat c'est la première fois depuis
mars 2021 qu'elle les reçoit ensemble
après de longues semaines de dialogue
social en panne est-ce que vous pensez
possible aujourd'hui la vraie reprise
d'un dialogue social
[Musique]
salut le dialogue on s'entend on
s'écoute pas forcément entre le le
syndicats et le gouvernement donc il
faut aujourd'hui que le dialogue
reprenne et qu'on fasse pas les mêmes
erreurs c'est à dire que le texte futur
texte qui va arriver soit sorte avec des
des reprises de proposition des deux
côtés des syndicats du gouvernement mais
qu'on est en vrai dialogue parce
qu'aujourd'hui le dialogue en fait il a
pas eu lieu on va parler d'un autre
texte le Sénat qui a donc voté cette
nuit la loi pour le plein emploi on va
voir avec 48 heures d'avance exactement
on va voir les mesures de ce texte et
les temps forts de cette séance avec
notre journaliste bonjour
[Musique]
bonjour Oriane bonjour Pierre Antonelli
bonjour et Samia le Sénat vient donc
d'adopter ce projet de lot à
plein-emploi avec deux jours d'avance
Pierre-Antoine Lévy le disait sur le
calendrier principal mesure voter hier
un durcissement des sanctions pour les
bénéficiaires du RSA qui ne respectent
pas leur engagement la suspension
remobilisation c'est donc une nouvelle
sanction votée hier au Sénat une
sanction intermédiaire qui est censée
intervenir avant la radiation d'un côté
donc une suspension temporaire du RSA en
cas de non-respects des engagements du
bénéficiaire et de l'autre s'il respecte
de nouveau ses engagements les
allocations lui seront remboursées de
manière rétroactive ça c'est la partie
remobilisation la majorité sénatorielle
de droite et du centre a donc voulu
durcir cette sanction proposée par le
gouvernement elle a fait voter une
limitation à trois mois de remboursement
maximum des allocations en cas de
suppression donc par exemple si un
allocataire du RSA voit ses allocations
suspendues pendant 6 mois et qu'il
remplit de nouveau ses engagements au
bout de 6 mois il ne serait remboursé
que de trois mois et non pas de six
comme le prévoyait le texte du
Gouvernement initialement ça a donc été
voté par la droite sénatoriale sans que
le gouvernement ne s'y oppose la gauche
elle évidemment était totalement contre
regardez l'intervention de la sénatrice
communiste Laurence Cohen le message que
vous envoyez au bénéficiaire du RSA
c'est aller si vous êtes de cils et que
vous faites finalement ce que l'on vous
demande on lève la punition les
associations de lutte contre la pauvreté
ont dénoncé ces méthodes basées sur les
sanctions tant elles savent les
conséquences désastreuses qu'elles vont
avoir sur les plus précaires dans un
contexte de crise économique d'inflation
depuis des mois votre réforme est
mortifère le RSA c'est un peu plus de
600 euros pour une personne seule c'est
souvent leur seule ressource est-ce
qu'on peut vraiment priver ces personnes
de tout revenu au risque de les faire
basculer dans la très grande pauvreté
comme la craint la gauche hier dans
l'hémicycle
encore une fois ce que nous avons voté
au Sénat c'est
proposition que nous avons porté
majorité sénatoriale pour donner un
cadre un peu plus strict au versement
d'une allocation nous versions des
allocations c'est un devoir pour la
nation des dés les plus précaires mais
également en contrepartie ces
allocataires doivent respecter les
règles alors encore une fois c'est le
vote du Sénat en première lecture il va
y avoir le texte va passer à l'Assemblée
nationale la semaine prochaine nous
allons voir ce que vont décider les
députés et quel texte vont-ils faire
puisque encore une fois le le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale vont devoir
négocier une position de principe avec
la commission mixte paritaire qui va se
réunir certainement la semaine prochaine
ou la semaine d'après notre position à
nous c'est trois mois
le rétroactivité et pourtant on
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de personnes
qui auraient le droit au RSA qui ne
réclame pas la gauche hier à donner des
chiffres en dans l'hémicycle 34% de non
recours ça représente 600 000 foyers
est-ce qu'avec ce genre de sanctions on
ne risque pas de dissuader encore
davantage de gens de réclamer leurs
droits pas forcément encore une fois le
l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est d'aller
accompagner les gens qui sont
allocataires du RSA pour la plupart pour
retrouver un emploi ça c'était notre
position parce qu'aujourd'hui je
rappelle que le le texte s'est retrouvé
le plein d'emploi avec un objectif de 5%
de taux de chômage à horizon 2027 l'idée
également c'est que tous les
allocataires de RSA sont inscrits
aujourd'hui 40% uniquement des
allocataires de RSA sont inscrits à Pôle
Emploi bon donc la rétroactivité jusqu'à
trois mois c'est pour on estime qu'en 3
mois on a peut-être un peu le temps
aussi de voir pourquoi la locataire n'a
pas respecté ces engagements comment
peut-on l'accompagner pour qu'il ait
respect à nouveau l'objectif c'est pas
de faire durer le débat pour lui faire
perdre 3 mois d'allocation
mais c'est également pour que nous
soyons plus réactifs en la matière voilà
donc trois mois c'est une date qui nous
paraît cohérente s'il faut la l'allonger
peut-être que le l'Assemblée nationale
va proposer autre chose et que nous
négocierons en commission mixte
paritaire notre position de principe
c'est cela c'est 3 mois bien quels sont
les engagements que doit remplir les
allocataires du RSA et c'était c'est
précis c'est un contrat d'engagement qui
a été voté la veille dans ce même projet
de loi pour toucher leur RSA les
bénéficiaires devront désormais
s'acquitter d'une contrepartie des
heures d'activité c'était une promesse
de campagne d'Emmanuel Macron mais dans
son texte initialement le gouvernement
ne prévoit pas le nombre d'heures le
Sénat l'a fait 15 heures d'activité
c'est le contrat d'engagement voter dans
la version sénatoriale du texte pour
rappel cette loi vous l'avez dit elle
est censée permettre d'atteindre le
plein emploi notamment grâce à un
accompagnement renforcé des demandeurs
d'emploi et des allocataires du RSA sauf
que forcément ça demande des moyens et
sur ce point la majorité sénatoriale qui
soutient pourtant le texte est assez
sceptique c'est René Paul Savary qui a
relayé cette inquiétude hier dans
l'hémicycle regardez
pour les présidents de départements
c'est difficile de savoir que des
personnes on peut pas leur proposer
suffisamment d'accompagnement pour les
sortir de leur difficulté et c'est
difficile parce qu'on n'a pas forcément
les moyens donc pour que votre projet
réussisse avec notre soutien encore
faudra-t-il y mettre les moyens
j'insiste lourdement monsieur le
ministre mais faut être très vigilant au
moment de du vote du projet de loi de
finance alors d'un côté on prévoit on
l'a dit en des sanctions assez dures en
cas de non-respects des engagements pour
les allocataires du RSA 15 heures
d'activité mais de l'autre pour
l'instant on voit pas les moyens pour
permettre d'accompagner ces personnes
pour les aider à atteindre cet objectif
alors que ce sont parfois des personnes
qui sont dans une grande difficulté
comment sont-elles censées faire s'il y
a pas les moyens pour les accompagner
prévus dans le texte la mise en place de
ce projet de loi va être étudié dans le
cas du projet loi de finance et c'est là
que nous allons voir si le gouvernement
met les moyens pour mettre en place ce
projet plein d'emploi qui doit démarrer
en janvier 2024 donc c'est la loi de
finances qui va déterminante on épaule
saveur il a dit on ne peut pas donner
des contraintes si on met pas de moyens
donc on sera extrêmement vigilant là
aussi faites nous confiance au Sénat
pour vérifier que les moyens soient mis
en oeuvre on ne peut pas donner en tout
cas il faut être logique dans dans les
voies de nouveaux temps on peut pas être
sévère avec nos concitoyens et ne pas
nous donner les moyens pour pouvoir
appliquer la loi
pourquoi va voulu inscrire ces 15 heures
parce qu'elles étaient pas inscrites
dans le taxe initial c'est 15 heures
d'activité pourquoi avoir voulu les
inscrire noire sur noir sur blanc et ne
pas les laisser comme un objectif ce que
souhaitait à la base de gouvernement
simplement parce que ça fait plusieurs
années que nous militons pour on va dire
une reconnaissance de la verte du
versement de ces allocations par le
biais du travail aujourd'hui on
considère que cette location est doit
être versée au plus précaire qui doit
être versé et aller verser un très grand
nombre de gens malheureusement c'est
c'est dur très très dur à dire mais il
faut une contrepartie et aujourd'hui
l'objectif c'est de montrer certaines
qu'on peut se réhabiliter revenir dans
une vie sociale par le travail 15 heures
d'activité ça nous paraît cohérent alors
encore une fois avec des des situations
très particulières à étudier en fonction
des cas vous avez toutes les personnes
ne pourront pas s'y conformer et il
faudra qu'on soit bien sûr intelligent
pour pouvoir être moins sévère en cas de
non respect pour des raisons médicales
par exemple ou des raisons de mobilité
donc 15h c'est ça nous paraît encore une
fois nous verrons ce que l'Assemblée
nationale propose l'autre volet de cet
accès à la création de France travail
qui vise à rassembler tous les acteurs
publics de l'emploi pour que les
allocataires des minimas sociaux et les
demandeurs d'emploi n'est plus qu'une
seule porte d'entrée vous avez souhaité
que Pôle emploi ne change pas de nom
Pôle emploi qui doit être intégré dans
France travail pourquoi simplement parce
que France travaille c'est l'opérateur
qui va justement
diriger les processus que soit
l'émission locale Cap emploi et Pôle
emploi on n'a pas voulu qu'il y ait de
confusion anthropologue entre Pôle
emploi et France travail et France
travail voilà tout simplement donc pour
nous Pôle emploi doit rester Pôle emploi
il y avait une inquiétude des
collectivités sur la création de ce
nouveau réseau notamment une crainte de
recentralisation est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
ces inquiétudes
je pense qu'elles sont levées
parce que les collectivités ne devaient
pas perdre en compétences avec son texte
sont très accompagnatrices les
collectivités justement sur le plan
local
on le voit quand on voit les moyens qui
sont mis à disposition les collectivités
jouent un rôle très important les
communautés d'agglomérations dans la
recherche d'emploi pour nos concitoyens
donc je pense que il faudrait être là
aussi une fois vigilant mais je suis pas
forcément inquiet là-dessus on disait
l'objectif de ce texte d'atteindre le
plein emploi c'est l'objectif du
gouvernement 100% de 5 % de chômage en
2027 est-ce que ça vous paraît
atteignable d'autant que Bruno Le Maire
ne se montre pas très optimiste sur les
prévisions de croissance à venir ça me
parait très ambitieux mais
on a réagissera en fonction des des
prévisions de croissance d'inflation qui
vont nous arriver vous savez c'est très
compliqué aujourd'hui de naviguer à 4-5
ans 2027 c'est dans trois ans et demi
quatre ans on a connu on va dire des
variations ces deux dernières années ça
me paraît ambitieux mais bon pourquoi
pas
merci beaucoup on se retrouve tout à
l'heure
oui sur le tableau de bord des
personnalités politiques de juillet 2023
on va voir ça avec vous à tout à l'heure
Samia dans le club on va parler d'un
dossier que vous suivez particulièrement
au Sénat à Pierre-Antoine Lévis c'est
celui des étudiants et du pouvoir
d'achat des étudiants vous auriez
souhaiter poser une question d'actualité
au Gouvernement sur les prêts étudiants
qu'est-ce que vous auriez demandé au
ministre et aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit
qu'avec la hausse ghetto bah déjà le les
étudiants payent de plus en plus cher
pour financer leurs études ensuite vous
avez des taux d'intérêt qui varient en
fonction du site d'études plus l'étude
le site d'études est élevé c'est-à-dire
les grandes écoles moins le taux
d'intérêt est élevé
et ça veut dire que sur des des grandes
écoles qui peuvent être des hecs et
compagnies vous pouvez avoir des taux
très bas et pour des BTS des toits un
peu plus élevés donc déjà il y a pas de
égalité dans les matières traitement
donc ensuite vous avez des
problématiques également de caution vous
avez des parents qui ont pas les moyens
de se porter caution pour les enfants
pourquoi ne pas mettre en place une
caution je l'avais proposé à l'époque
caution de la BPI par exemple ou du
gouvernement pour jusqu'à 30 40 000
euros pour financer les cycles d'études
et permettre à tous les étudiants
d'avoir les mêmes chances parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un vrai c'est un
vrai sujet vous avez des étudiants qui
ont du mal à se loger quand on a du mal
à se nourrir qui ont du mal à faire des
études qui arrêtent leurs études parce
que les parents ou eux-mêmes n'ont pas
les moyens de les financer ça c'est
quand même difficile donc
je suis assez sur massif vigilant au
Sénat là-dessus mais
je poserai la question un peu plus tard
on va il y a un autre sujet que vous
suivez parce que vous êtes membre de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication et vous avez notamment
travaillé sur la concentration des
médias la rédaction du Journal du
Dimanche à reconduit sa grève pour
s'opposer à la nomination de Geoffroy
Lejeune à la tête de la rédaction est-ce
que vous faites partie des personnes qui
sont inquiète d'une forme de main mise
de Vincent Bolloré sur les médias
alors il y a deux points qu'il faut
aborder dans votre dans votre question
alors je vais pas interférer sur la
grève du JDD la rédaction JDD refuse
l'arrivée de Geoffroy Lejeune alors on
peut s'étonner effectivement de
l'arrivée au JDD de ces personnages qui
a été dégagé de valeur actuelle parce
qu'il était considéré comme to Street
trop pas droite et donc c'est vrai que
ça peut paraître surprenant que j'offre
les jeunes soit embauchés à la rédaction
de du JDD
non je pense pas qu'il m'a mise de
Vincent Bolloré par contre on peut
parler des propos qui ont été tenus il y
a quelques jours par papendaye sur sur
les médias notamment où il a jugé il y a
quelques sur Europe 1 c'est nous en
considérant que repeint cnews était les
journaux d'extrême droite je trouve
quand même que ce sont des propos
absolument rien qualifiable
je condamnais aujourd'hui d'abord je
vois pas en quoi il peut qualifier que
Europe 1 la rédaction d'Europe et de
sinus et aujourd'hui Alexandre j'avais
une pluralité d'information et d'abord
l'information doit être libre et pluriel
et la ministre a pas interféré justement
dans le choix rédactionnel pour moi il a
fait une faute mais sur l'appareil il a
pas il a pas donné alors il peut donner
son avis mais son avis de ministres
c'est pas forcément la vie des Français
d'ailleurs je pense que les rédactions
ont réagi en conséquence
on va aller voir
l'actualité dans nos régions on va aller
à Orléans retrouver Éric Richard
journaliste à La Nouvelle République
bonjour Eric merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous Éric la Nouvelle République qui
s'intéresse aujourd'hui à la
rémunération des patrons du CAC 40 qui
n'a jamais cessé d'augmenter depuis des
décennies et oui c'est
toujours davantage dans le sait les plus
vulnérables alors que les puissants en
sortent semble-t-il toujours un peu plus
riche alors évidemment lorsque le
pouvoir d'achat du plus grand nombre est
en berne bien la rémunération du PDG du
groupe automobile stellantis par exemple
presque 1200 fois supérieur à la moyenne
des salaires de sa propre entreprise et
a fait un peu grincer les dents mais il
y a un chiffre plus éloquent encore
c'est celui-ci entre le début des années
60 et aujourd'hui l'écart de
rémunération entre le salaire moyen et
le grand dirigeant et bien a été
multiplié par 20 en d'autres termes le
pouvoir d'achat de l'ouvrier s'est
considérablement accru en si décennie
c'est irréfutable et c'est tant mieux
mais si ce salarié a bénéficié des
fruits de la croissance ce n'est pas lui
qui a consommé disons les plus juteux et
une loi de 2001 imposée à publicité des
rémunérations des dirigeants des
entreprises cotées en bourse n'a-t-elle
pas permis de clarifier et de pondérer
les choses avec mais pas vraiment et
c'est là justement le paradoxe tout au
plus cette publicité donne l'occasion on
le sait chaque année au syndicat mais
aussi au gouvernement voir au chef de
l'État lui-même il y a de s'offusquer de
la hausse exponentielle des revenus d'un
dirigeant du CAC 40 par exemple dans
l'entreprise n'assise pourtant pas de
résultats mirobolant sauf qu'au-delà de
les farouchements de circonstances on ne
peut pas plafonner bien sûr comme c'est
le cas pour une entreprise publique la
rémunération d'un dirigeant dans le
contrat relève du droit privé et c'est
là que la loi de 2001 sur les nouvelles
régulations économiques vous l'avez dit
la fameuse loi NRE bien n'a pas eu
l'effet escompté tant tous les cas la
vie de Frédéric Frery universitaire
professeur à l'École Supérieure de
Commerce de Paris est spécialiste du
management pour lui les règles qui
fixent la rémunération d'un grand PDG
n'ont rien à voir avec disons les
principes ordinaires du monde du travail
il s'agit de mettre en confiance les
marchés de montrer que l'on charge bien
des plus hautes fonctions un personnage
hors norme en quelque sorte et au-dessus
de tous la meilleure façon de le prouver
bien c'est lui accorder une rémunération
hors norme elle aussi pour Frédéric
Frery ce serait aussi simple que cela
aussi simple et aussi pervers et pour
lui s'ajoute aussi une émulation forte
entre ces grands dirigeants à l'ego
disons-le rarement sous dimensionné plus
habitué à gagner qu'à perdre et qui
mettrait un point d'honneur à bénéficier
d'une meilleure rémunération que le
concurrent et c'est ainsi que pour
Frédéric frairie bien on aurait les
meilleures chances de rompre avec cette
spirale en revenant paradoxalement au
principe de confidentialité sauf que ce
serait vécu comme un tel camouflé à la
transparence qu'évidemment ça semble
politiquement un peu impossible alors je
me tourne vers monsieur le sénateur Lévy
il y a tout simplement pour vous
demander votre avis et votre regard sur
cette question la loi notamment
pourrait-elle évoluer et disons mieux
faire
bonne question
c'est très détaillé alors déjà on va
parler de la rémunération des grands
patrons il faut aussi se comparer quand
on se compare les rémunération des
grands patrons du CAC 40 s'aperçoit que
la France est vraiment pas le pays qui
paye le mieux ces dirigeants vous avez
je crois qu'elle est 5e en terme de
rémunération vous avez l'Allemagne qui
paye je crois le double en terme de
moyenne le Dax qui est l'équivalent d'Ax
30 qui est l'équivalent du CAC 40 c'est
deux fois plus payé deux fois plus les
dirigeants que que la France
l'Angleterre également l'Italie le
Danemark donc je dis pas que c'est une
comparaison comme une autre mais il faut
également déjà relativiser ensuite les
rémunérations des grands patrons sont
également votées aussi en assemblée
générale donc il y a quand même de la
transparence les actionnaires peuvent
très bien refuser de voter telle
rémunération telle
bonus à un patron je crois aussi que
nos grands patrons
il faut pas les perdre vraiment des
grands patrons français
et quand on voit également quand ils
sont payés aux États-Unis si nous payons
pas suffisamment alors encore une fois
pas suffisamment je dis pas qu'il faut
payer 8 10 millions d'euros un patron
français mais il y a un tel écart entre
les le la rémunération d'un patron pays
aux États-Unis un patron payé en France
qu'on pourrait perdre éventuellement nos
grands patrons et que nous perdrions
notre savoir-faire aujourd'hui qui est
quand même le nôtre donc moi je pense
qu'il faut
pas que le gouvernement se mêle des
rémunérations mais par contre qui un
partage de valeur
parce que c'est ça aussi quand vous avez
des sociétés qui font d'énormes
bénéfices il faut que les salariés
puissent profiter de ces bénéfices et
qui est un partage de valeur
suffisamment cohérent pour éviter
d'aborder de la distension au sein de
l'entreprise on a entendu parler que les
patrons s'étaient payés beaucoup plus
sur le partage la loi sur le partage
chez nous et on verra comment la
modifier mais effectivement il faut
qu'il y ait plus de partage de valeur
mais
il faut faire attention
aux messages qu'on va envoyer également
peut-être aussi peut-on se poser la
question puisqu'on parle de rémunération
des rémunérations qu'on donne à nos
footballeurs
qui sont très très bien payés aussi
peut-être des fois payés un mois plus
que nos patrons sur l'année donc il y a
également cette question qu'on peut se
poser vous savez les grands footballeurs
pour les grands footballeurs donc la
question de la rémunération est
importante partage de valeur
essentielles des sportifs je pense qu'il
faut avoir de la cohérence c'est à dire
que si on commence à encadrer les
salaires des grands patrons peut-être
qu'il faut avoir une réflexion pour
éviter une surenchère là aussi mais
c'est pareil on les paye beaucoup parce
que si on les paye pas suffisamment ils
partent à l'étranger et on perd nos nos
pépites mais il faut avoir une réflexion
globale je pense
on va regarder
la Nouvelle République l'hébergement
d'urgence sature merci
d'avoir beaucoup Pierre Antoine Lévy
merci d'avoir été notre invité pendant
cette première demi-heure dans 20
minutes dans le club d'État et toi on
parlera des risques de sécheresse que
les élus doivent gérer pour économiser
l'eau l'agglomération de Chambéry où on
ira faire le choix de fermer plus
longtemps l'une de ces piscines mais
d'abord on va accueillir notre prochaine
invité manuel bon pardon aux gens